in your bookmark what I'd like you to
turn to is wherever you did I think it's
set for a for a and wherever you did
questions four and five in set for a so
for those of you who you were a
submitter bookmark three I started to
write this as a comment on a reply to
your bookmark as something to watch out
for but so many people are doing it I
realize is probably because i had a
torta clearly and it's been a while like
this was just revision for us right so
I'm going to reteach this idea because
actually connects really well into in
verse 3 okay so we look at questions
four and five let's pick out one likes a
should we go five because this is the
one that I think the last question there
saw that you want to help with ok so I
think it says this always okay yes
can you shout outs to themselves okay so
there's the question right now I think
most of you either by recognizing it or
ask your friend right you noticed even
though it's like it's your like it's
half angle right but half angle is
really the same as double angle just in
Reverse right so we use this identity
let's let's make it let's put it back in
terms of double angle okay if I work
what's the view in terms of high speed
is rather than riding clothes squared
minus side squared I'll write it like
this okay yes so you rearrange a little
bit and eventually I think you get to
this point 1 plus that's right yeah now
he's the critical point where I want you
to take notice okay because at at this
line um yeah I don't think I saw anyone
who did a right which is probably my
fault because I didn't imagine it but
most people are going straight to hear
they're saying well I'll take the square
root of both sides and this is what you
get and the clue the value of cos theta
or cos x or whatever is given to you so
I sorry this should be pushing it to
them too yeah that's right then you
pretty the number and you get some
fraction at the end and you check your
answer and it's right so you're like
great I just move on right but there's a
problem what's the problem yeah that's
right i mean just strictly speaking from
here to here there ought to be a plus or
minus there right so the plus is one of
the answers but we just sort of ignored
the negative like why why do we ignore
the negative and why does the answer
ignore the negative why is there only
one solution okay so bring your back
over here right what this would be equal
to if it's in terms of not two thieves
and theatres but exes
some too you'll get plus or minus the
square root of 1 minus plus ok now just
like you know in measurement problems
where you're trying to solve a quadratic
right and that you get something at the
end in his two solutions right and there
might be what is negative okay you're
like well it can't be negative yeah
because it's a length or it's a time or
something that I'm going to measure okay
in exactly the same way you can't just
ignore the negative air tub and just
forget that it ever industry okay you
need to recognize it and then justify
why you can't ignore it ok so I can't
say yes it's true that it is equal to
this value but the question is why the
question is why okay so I want to give
you a of a counter example and you stop
me when you can see where the
justification is ok let's try out say
let's go back to hear will stay will
stay with this one okay let's take a
value for x okay so let's say let x
equal say three ply on 23 pounds with
right should network yeah I don't work
ok so quads are three planet ooh what's
that equal to me cause I three punches
what does was close dude it goes down
and then it comes back up right so
where's three pile onto its
it's a category I drove here we go it
goes down and it comes back up that's
too high right half ways high-waist
through plan to it's it's one and a half
pyrites hasn't going to learn to sew
like dangerous over the last five
minutes in 0 ok 0 their problems okay
now if I were to follow through with
this idea here alright i would say cause
of exon 2 which is three pile for now i
know i can evaluate that on its own
right but i want to see what happens
when they use this identity which I've
just sort of color it right it should be
plus or minus the square root of 1 plus
cos x which in this case is zero on to
write so simplify a little bit you get
this ok now this point we clearly know
something is wrong right because close
through pine for slime variable it's an
actual number it's it's it's only gone
one value and you can actually see you a
three point four is on this diagram
right there's pie that's a pile to there
so where's 3 PI over 4 it's it's halfway
between those two right there's three
powerful okay so you can see this must
be the the negative oil 2-1 on route 2
okay so hold on a second in this case
it's actually minus Orleans route
because you know in this domain from
plan to 23 mar 2
that implies that context is negative ok
so wait in this case I just took the
negative one and disregard the positive
whereas when most people solve this
question they did the exact reverse and
it seemed to work out so my question is
how can you know either can I disregard
the negative like this can I disregard
the positive like this or in what cases
can I not disregard either them like
I've gotta keep both in check can anyone
tell me go back to the question does it
give you any clues right ok so Chloe
back to this one here right you're given
this domain yes so X X has to be letting
between not 90 ok now what that means is
that cause of X 12 if I just take this
right divide everything through by 2
that means not only is our X cubed it's
between 0 and PI and for ok now come
back to cons between 0.4 news is this
kind of area in here right so cause of X
onto whatever its value is I don't know
its exact value yeah it has to be
positive because in that domain it's
positive right so here the reason why I
can get rid of one of the answer is I
can say as cos x
as I had this restriction right so
therefore cos x must be positive okay so
you have to with that just like if you
were doing a quadratic you'd have to say
I condition regards negative because too
late or try for something that has to
have positive 9
okay now the important thing want to get
across is like sometimes it'll be the
negative that you disregard right so you
need to start to get used to thinking
about what angles you've got and whether
it makes your final result once you
process it through some trig functions
or inverse trig function whether you'll
get something positive or negative at
the other end okay it's going to be
really important for industry because it
just goes it's not so clear cut as here
there's another step of abstraction okay
so we'll look at those tomorrow morning
but for now all I want you to make sure
is if I handed your bookmark back to you
go back to the sections where you're
answering questions like this there's a
few of them okay and make sure you
include this slide it's badly important
in fact you may even like to write the
line before this one here because a lot
of you just skipped it entirely okay so
go back to put it in another color and
yeah make it a bit problem thanks
well in this case they just give it to
you like this state it must be cute I'm
strictly speaking we actually can up we
could know a little war we can say if I
want to take the positive square root
okay I actually have a I can have a
bigger domain than being between 0.2 I
can actually be all the way from 0 to PI
right because there when i do when i
divide everything through by 2x or two
will be a queue right and therefore it's
going to cause of the acute angles will
be positive okay but in this case they
actually said yeah this is this data so
you know that's that's you know they
could have said it was less than I